[Music]
in this crazy world we're living in
filled with fear and manipulation and
uncertainty there is one strategy to get
through it all
love the grammy nominated singer aloe
blacc is out there
preaching love and inspiring us all to
fight with love and fight for love
this is a bit of optimism
it's good to see you good to see you too
one of my favorite things about you
is you have this amazing calm about you
i don't think i've ever seen you get
riled up you're so even keeled
have you always been that way or was it
something you cultivated
you know i wouldn't say i've always been
this way
i have a distinct memory of being
in high school playing a game of
dodgeball
and on the other side of the line
were two friends of mine and they were
targeting me in such a way that made me
feel
as though they were no longer my friends
and so i got so upset and i got
so irate and i lost it
and when i lost it and i came back down
and i got
calm again i said i'm never gonna do
that again
i'm never gonna lose my mind in that way
and since then i've always
balanced every situation and scenario
and just paid attention to what
is at stake and recognized cooler heads
will prevail
i'm a reactor i used to have a terrible
temper as a kid
i mean like terrible terrible temper
tantrums
and i used to break things and throw
things it was really
bad and i had this kite it was like my
pride and joy this kite from bali
that you couldn't fly it was just really
cool and hanging on my wall with huge
wings
and i was so angry one day i ripped off
the wall and like
destroyed this thing that i love out of
anger and then when i came down
i was like oh come on
i couldn't blame anyone because i broke
my own thing
and like you i was like okay this has
got to stop because if i'm going to
break things that i
care about this has to stop now
were your parents calm no my parents are
from panama
and so the energy is very latin not to
like stereotype people but
the the way that they speak the energy
they speak with
is just on another level from
what i'd consider like the standard
american speech
of just like how we're speaking right
now yeah or or even like
collegiate debate you know it wasn't
collegiate debate
it was definitely at the
loudest volume with the the highest
sense of emotion and i recognized that
and i thought is it really necessary
is that really going to work it's all
these things i process and
as i you know manage my own marriage
with maya
i think about like i don't want to yell
i don't want to argue
i want to get down to solutions and
facts yeah
and we're living in a world that is so
polarized right now
where if i'm right you must be wrong
and i justify my rightness because i
believe in my own convictions
so where's the lesson like how do we
have belief in our convictions
but not think that we're so right that
that everyone else is wrong or become
close-minded to
another point of view when we turn off
the social media the unfortunate thing
about social media the echo chamber
at the algorithms that keep us amused
and entertained by the thoughts and
ideas that we already have shown the
algorithm that we appreciate
and that keep us interested and this is
the issue
we're getting so much confirmation of
our
own biases from this algorithmic
deluge of information that it's
completely drowning out opposition or
rationality
let me push you a little bit there so
let's pretend that
social media goes dead for whatever
reason it's hacked
facebook and instagram and tick tock it
all just
stops it disappears we still have our
echo chambers
in our friend groups we tend to share in
general
hopefully the same values with all of
our friends but we tend to share
similar belief sets as well in similar
politics as our friends
and you and i have both been in these
conversations where you sit amongst your
friends
and somebody starts something whether
it's political or something and
everybody chimes in and it's all the
same conversation we're not actually
learning or adding to anything and then
we walk away going that was great
because all of our
biases were affirmed by this friend
group how do we
learn to want to be curious
about someone outside our friend group
or even invite someone into our friend
group
who shares our values but may have very
different political opinions
this is really difficult and you're
right it's not just because of social
media
these kind of things existed before um i
think they're exacerbated certainly
by technology i think we've also
conflated politics and values and for me
the organization of society is politics
like that's that's pretty much it so how
do you organize society that's politics
well you organize society based upon
values so let me elaborate
first or what i mean about the
conflation of politics and values which
is
i have some friendships that i'm very
proud of because we have very different
political points of view
and the reason we still are good friends
is because there are things that are
more important to us than
our political points of view for example
being there for each other
offering each other a safe space to be
our true selves
listening making sure the other person
feels heard empathy you know all of
these things
right the point is our politics are
separated
from our friendship our politics are
separated from our values i think
survival
is what holds people together guaranteed
and if you think about the evolution of
of the human being
we're not a very strong animal us versus
elephant
[Music]
even us versus horse it's not gonna go
well for us
us versus microscopic virus we're not
that strong
we couldn't survive in nature alone we
need each other
and so we had to adapt to be come social
we had to learn things like trust
because literally our survival depended
on it
and even getting along with people that
we quote unquote didn't like because
you need me and i need you right i think
the evolution of politics
and that doesn't mean that there isn't
uh conflict of course there's conflict
even
amongst cooperative animals but i think
the evolution of politics
is when things started to become more
abstract and then we start defending
abstractions without actually finding
out if it's true or not
and that goes back to your point of the
echo chamber william yuri the guy who
wrote getting to yes
was an amazing guy he
[Music]
shared a statistic with me recently
which is
when interviewing republicans democrats
over 50 percent of republicans believe
that democrats
would do them harm and over 50 percent
of
democrats believe that republicans
would do them harm the real number
is three percent and so what ends up
happening
is you now have two groups of people
represented by
people who are more interested in
getting reelected than actually doing
the right thing so it's
that's a whole different conversation
who are now
making decisions out of fear that the
other would do them harm
when the reality is neither presents a
threat to the other
that's politics to me it's making policy
it's making decisions it's making a
campaign promise
all based on an abstract concept that
has no basis
in fact whatsoever all right so a false
value
false value and this abstraction
is real when it comes to the point where
someone's civil rights are being
violated
right that abstraction is extremely real
yes because now it's the impact
of an abstraction right now i'm making
policy or actually doing things based on
abstraction
and the problem is the impact is very
very real
that's something that i've been thinking
about lately as well like
yes i may not agree with your beliefs
and you may be completely wrong if we
were to do any scientific analysis on
what you believe
but the fact that you believe it and
that you have
a strong conviction in it is still
relevant
because it is key to
our ultimate survival as a species
if we end up fighting over it you know
if you believe it is worth
life or death and you hear it in the
rhetoric right
let's go down an uncomfortable path you
you
raise civil rights yeah and so
when some people hear about the fear
that african-americans have
going outside or if you get pulled over
for speeding sure
the reaction is but you have nothing to
fear
it's a few bad apples like most of the
time it's gonna be fine like
it's a very rational answer based on
their perspective
and i heard a statement by a police
chief very recently
because there's such anger against the
police right now
that he started talking about his
officers
there's a lot of fear and how
he now is keenly aware that if one of
his officers takes their squad car
home and parks the police car in the
driveway
that that then identifies him and makes
his house a target
there's real fear and in that experience
he instantly understands
the fear a black person a black person
feels all of a sudden for the first time
in his policing career
he's a white male he has this incredible
empathy
that this cop is going to be afraid to
walk outside of his front door
and now he understands the fear the
black man that fear that exists
that to me is a perfect platform
for them to relate to each other and for
a conversation to start
yeah and so recognizing
these abstractions that ultimately can
have
real consequences to your existence
yeah the fear is real yeah fear is real
and so
how do we get people to recognize
the value in having these alternate
opinions
and being open to discussing them is so
difficult i think
i i would say it comes down to how
you're raised were you in a household or
were you in a community that allowed
open debate respectful discussion
agreeing to disagree and still be
cordial
that kind of thing is important because
if you were raised in an environment
where
differing ideas meant fists and dueling
then that's
going to be your your response i want to
keep going down this path of fear
for a little longer it's really
interesting if you think about the
society we're living in right now
there's fear mongering that is done for
political gain
there is fear used even quote unquote
innocently
in marketing we see it on the news all
the time you know
can drinking water give you cancer tune
in at seven
you know like we use fear
to manipulate behaviors all the time we
do it with our kids
it's done at work you better do as
you're told or you might get fired
and mass layoffs have become so
pervasive like fear is the thing that's
driving a lot of behavior
and if fear is an abstraction which has
real impact but
fear is an abstraction what do we do as
a society what do we do as individuals
to overcome our fears for the good of
ourselves our families our communities
society etc so the only thing that only
answer i have is love
i don't know exactly how to implement it
in a policy
but this is what i do with my music i
try to promote
the concept of compassion empathy love
togetherness
recognition inspiring others motivating
others
being there for others and comforting
people because
as i was developing my career there was
a lot of
angst political angst and social angst
and i wanted to rage against the machine
like one of my favorite bands
and i thought it's only going to make me
tired it's only going to make me a
target
what if i try to throw
love into the equation how does the
machine
function when it's confronted with love
and i think
it ends up being very difficult for fear
to thrive
where there is an abundance
of love because that abundance of love
comforts another to feel
like they will be protected like they
will be
heard like they will be valued
that abundance of love is such an
important piece of
what is missing in society and in
our media like you said the news media
works based on fear
my music industry works based on fear
the majority of the top 10 songs are
going to be about
brokenheartedness so the fear of
rejection
violence and gun play so the fear of
death
and then when you go to films and tvs
it's the same thing it's you know the
violence and the
scary movies so what i found to be the
biggest
challenge is to use love as my
calling card in an industry
that really thrives billions and
billions of dollars off of
pulling at your primordial fears
this is a perfectly good segue you grew
up
the son of a marine that your dad was a
marine
and i had the opportunity to spend some
time with marines
i have a soft spot in my heart for them
and
i asked maureen what is the secret like
what is it that makes the marine corps
so good and he looked this is a this is
a hardcore warrior
and he looked at me and he said love he
said love of love of country
love of core love of your fellow marine
yeah
that's it i mean and they they make it
so salient from the beginning when you
first get in they
completely destroy your concept of the
world that you came from
and everything then becomes this new
world that you're in
my dad was in the marines for 30 years
and upon coming out
he's so indoctrinated in the system that
the
world outside is just very strange
the marines have a a motto semper
fidelis
always faithful and that always faithful
has
order to it you're always faithful to
country always faithful to
god always faithful to your fellow
corpsman
and you follow the chain of command and
in the real world
there is no fidelity out in the outside
world
there's no promise of fidelity and
it really was um still is it's hard for
him to manage that there's no order
out in this world what kind of love
did you learn from your father that was
different from the kind of love you
learned from your mother
my dad loves as a provider my dad loves
as a doer and a producer
and so what i learned from him was that
love is
making sure the people that you are
responsible for
are always taken care of to any degree
that you have
to engage you do it in order to make it
happen
i remember hearing my dad talk about
running 25 like they run marathons
for in boot camp and him just saying
what got me through the last five miles
was thinking about you guys at back at
home
and that that sticks with me today like
i think
about my kids and of course my life is
completely different in the
the amount of physical effort that i
have to exert in order to
provide for my family is way different i
still think
about how much i'm willing to give to
make sure that my family is
taken care of the nurturing kind of love
came from more from my mother
my dad's love was i'm gonna put tiles
down in this bathroom
and you're gonna sit and watch me do it
and you're gonna help
pass me a tool when i need it because if
you know how to do if you know how to
produce if you know how to
create then you will never be
a spectator or subject to someone else's
will
you'll be able to control your own will
i had the opportunity to work out
with the 101st airborne and we got up
very early in the morning and we went to
the parking lot and we're doing all
these push-ups and you know
on the on the asphalt which is not fun
and at the end of
like 20-30 minutes i was like great
workout guys that was the warm-up
but when we actually went and did the
actual workout we did something called a
hero's workout
and what a hero's workout is they pull
out a piece of paper and they say today
we're working out
for someone and in this case it was an
airman a fallen airman
who had lost his life in combat
and before we work out they read the
circumstance
in which he was killed they tell us the
name of his children
they tell us the name of his wife they
tell us where he's from
how old he was and they say to us today
you're working out for him i remember
in the middle of the workout and these
are competitive guys you know
but none of us were pushing ourselves to
beat each other we were pushing
ourselves to outdo ourselves
and i remember like during a run someone
would be running past me and he'd tap me
on the back and go keep going
and when we were dragging i remember at
one point where i would just
i just was like huffing and puffing you
thought of this fallen airmen that we
were working out for and we had an
ins insurmountable insurmountable energy
that just poured through our veins
because now we were doing it for love
yeah we weren't doing it to prove
anything we weren't due to out doing
anything it wasn't competition
all the things that happened in the
outside world how we quote unquote drive
performance we pit people against each
other we offer them bonuses
all of these things and we were pushing
ourselves for love
yeah you know your question was how do
we
overcome the fear and what you've just
now mentioned is the answer
what you suggest in this example is
purpose
you had a purpose in okinawa i watched
this
documentary about what okinawans live so
long or
they have a high percentage of
sensogenarians and they have
a philosophy of ikigai or this the
concept of
purpose and everybody has a purpose the
older gentleman who still goes out to
fish every day
even though there's young guys who can
do it his purpose is to fish
the older women who certainly have their
daughters to raise the grandkids still
participate in the rearing of the
children
and i think that is part of what
love is is finding purpose in
doing for those around us i think you're
onto something here that's really
really powerful which is it has to be
specific
we talked about abstraction when purpose
is abstract
it actually doesn't work to be the best
or
to to provide or to be you know to make
an impact in the world
it's very abstract and what was so
profound
uh in the for the marines but also it
was so profound in this heroes workout
is we weren't working out for all the
fallen soldiers
which is abstract right they don't have
faces or names
what did stalin supposedly say you know
the death of one man as a tragedy the
death of a million is a statistic
right and when we did this hero's
workout and this person had a name
and an identity and a family all of a
sudden it became
non-abstract it became incredibly
tangible and incredibly personal
and incredibly inspiring and perhaps
purpose has to have a face and has to
have a name
you're right and the biggest challenge
then is
the american ideology of rugged
individualism
where we don't have any purpose related
to anyone else
right just about it's about self and how
much you can do
to get to where you want to get by any
means necessary
we over indexed and i think this is one
of the reasons why somebody can be
a bastard and all of a sudden they have
a child
and their whole life turns around
because they say for the first time
i feel like i'm everything i'm doing is
for summit all of a sudden purpose
again it has a face it has a name we're
going to need to figure out how to
develop this concept and have everybody
find purpose because at 13 years old
when arguably across any region around
the world
and across any time period that's when
you're supposed to rebel
how do you find purpose in order to grow
into a
an individual who has love
at the core rather than fear at the core
and by the way you don't have to know
these people like you don't have to have
a child the purpose doesn't have to be
for your child or your friend
remember this hero's workout none of us
knew him
he was in the air force where i'm with
the army i mean it was a completely
different uniform
and if you think about black lives
matter it's not an abstract thing
it was george floyd he had a name
he had a face that's really important
yeah it was for someone well it's always
for someone and that's part of
the call and movement for black lives
it's always to say their names
so that they are again not just
statistic and not forgotten
and so that it becomes more salient and
concrete a human being's life
was taken let's respect and value life
and let's figure out how to reform a
system
that ultimately seems to be broken
and likely is broken and needs to be
corrected in order to protect and serve
and just like those hero's
workout when we're exhausted and we
don't feel like we have anything left to
give
and we remind ourselves of their names
of their faces
of the details of their lives we find
the energy to persevere
yeah in order for that to work you have
to have an
a bone of empathy and so developing that
is
i think the precursor developing empathy
is important i believe in order to
recognize
that kind of purpose where you're
making it about someone yeah goes back
to love again
well yeah i just feel like that's the
answer
i mean what we're theorizing is if you
have love at home you're more likely to
develop that empathy muscle if you don't
have love in the home
or at least near the home school you
know i think education plays a big part
of it as well
i mean we all know about the teachers
who took a liking to us we can remember
their names
we can't remember all the other teachers
and every one of us is
we are who we are today in part because
of these few people this handful of
people whether it was a coach or a
teacher whoever it was who like for some
reason
seemed to love us seem to take us under
their wing yeah
because they had a boundless empathy
a boundless understanding of their
purpose
it makes me love what you do in your
music
even more i like your music because i
like the tunes you know
yeah i enjoy listening to your music but
now that
i have a deeper understanding of the
purpose of your music
it actually makes me like even the songs
that i don't
necessarily like if that makes sense
gotcha yeah no i guess i now
i now respect the purpose of your music
right so i think about the genre that i
grew up in hip-hop music
it educated me on how to write lyrics it
educated me on other genres because i
was sampling music from
classic rock and from jazz and from soul
music
listening to those lyricists and those
musicians
being informed and educated and
instructed on how to make
music outside of the genre of hip-hop
yet hip-hop was my
forte at the time as a young kid and
the type of music that inspired me most
was very
conscious it was about recognizing it
was there was a pro-black movement
within hip-hop in the in the 90s
that spoke to the african diaspora
it spoke to having self-pride and
wanting to better
the black community and then
there was a huge surge in
uh gangster rap which then had a
completely different narrative
while both narratives were true gangster
rap is a reflection of what
is actually happening in the
neighborhoods the
pro-black movement was a reflection of
what was growing in the neighborhoods to
be a
visionary movement towards
the betterment of the black community
the industry favored
the violence and the misogyny over the
visionary positivity
and ultimately i
decided that i wanted to continue
this movement of positive visionary
but expand it beyond just the black
community just make it a human
message and in opposition to what
the popular use of
the hip-hop genre was at the time which
ended up becoming gangster rap
and so when i had my first solo album
the title was shine through meaning
to let your soul shine through the
darkness
because if you allow the darkness to
swallow up the light then there will be
no hope
my second solo album title was
good things now the album itself
spoke to some of the hardships
in politics in inner city
society in relationships
but i titled it good things in
particular
to continue the theme of having hope
my third solo album was called lift your
spirit
so i use language in this way
to continue to be a beacon of light
and suggest positivity and of course
this most recent album is called
all love everything and i'm just
doubling down on love
all love and love everything there's no
way around it yeah
here's what i've learned from you today
i've learned that purpose is specific
that purpose is human
that if we have purpose we can endure
when we can share the desire to advance
for someone that we find
community and common cause even if our
politics are different
and this is what produces trust within
this community within this common cause
this drive to serve a human
is love love for each other and love for
for what we're serving and that goes
back to that love of country love of
core love of
love of your fellow marine i understand
that better now
i think that's important where you said
you started with
purpose but then you specify that
purpose has to be for
someone else it can't be for yourself um
right and maybe it can be i'm just no i
don't think positive i don't think it
can be
i think and i'm going to change my
language i used to say purpose is
for something but i think purpose is for
someone
i think it should be for someone
something is still abstract
yeah right because yeah
the thing could be an abstraction yeah
aloe you inspire me so much
oh likewise i'm i'm so happy that we we
get a chance to have these conversations
and
just come to new realizations yeah this
is great
thank you so much for taking the time i
really appreciate it my pleasure thank
you
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other